I'm very happy to be joined by camera
Robertson hey Danny Scotland yes a
second Scottish gone did you say free
day to freedom thank you say freedom
Peter Brown freedom nice down hide say
freedom freedom great okay Ozzie
American Scottish and I so yours is
closer to the film really yeah it's the
United color colors of benetton of video
games and we're here to talk about it pc
which is perhaps the most universally
popular a platform is want to call it
that and then all a little bunch of
other stuff as well first of all
hardware i want to ask you 1st peter
brown steam machines seems to be a keeps
coming up every time we talk about
conferences in particular mmm where are
we with steam machines what I had as a
steam machine they still haven't made
this like digestible ok Stevie Sheen is
a PC that's effectively priced to
compete with consoles but what it really
is as a machine that runs the steam OS
and supports pals controller valve is
now delayed that to 2015 yeah like
everything like everything they're
making inker incremental improvements to
steamos but again it's kind of like a
linux box right so it doesn't really
support a lot of the games that you find
on windows so honestly right now if
you've got steam installed on your
Windows PC and you run big picture mode
and you got a 360 controller you've
effectively got a steam machine at
cameron robinson i know you were at Eve
FanFest i was in a wonderful iceland
only two weeks ago i played them oculus
before never Valkyrie yeah Mon like when
the older units and putting on the dk2
especially having that like depth camera
like that was the biggest thing for me
because I go quite a lot of nausea
walking around the old Tuscan villa but
no Valkyrie at all because you stick it
on and you immediately you look at your
avatar yeah and it really helps like
place and get a sense of presence or was
for me it's weird because this time last
year oculus was still very much a this
might be a piece of technology that
people start to use yes that's happens
like we've had this with massive buyers
by Facebook and it's now you know
project Morpheus has been announced and
everything else what
I hate saying this and I know Peters
gonna jump on my neck and bite my lungs
out when I say this is V or actually not
going to be a fab this time around is
this something that people are we're
going to see more and more of it will be
like in extra be tied to gaming yeah I
think like the interesting thing is that
it's really kind of uniting the pc as a
platform the pc has never really had
anything at least two III to sort of
unify yeah what's on show Adam orth you
know the guy who was unceremoniously
dismissed from Microsoft after his
tweets he's working on a game that's
going to be at e3 it's not space sim but
you play as a spaceman in a space suit
that's running out of air so sort of
like gravity see you later and that's
gonna be something that's like at least
a unique first-person experience yay
talking about weird first person and
video game worlds are we going to see
mirrors edge to this I don't think
you're going to see that and star wars
battlefront battle down is definitely
gonna be there I think they're gonna
save mirrors edge 2 for a bit later and
I think there's a lot further off anyway
so well there is also the question that
Microsoft has this third-party exclusive
that supposed to keep people really
excited okay i have a few theories but
mirrors edge 2 could be one of them i
think even just teasing that a little
bit more might give them the sort of
excitement that they and the buzz that
they need from the audience you think
that's gonna be a microsoft exclusive it
could be i mean you know they
essentially if they're saying it look
there's a third party game that's coming
that's going to get people really
excited it's got to be something that we
already know about like in terms of a
franchise rights something that people
want and we've literally see nothing
except for this trailer at e3 yes yeah
like nothing else love y'all so be it be
great to have I almost feel like it
might be a better tactic for them to
continue showing nothing because this
trailer was so good and just reminded
everyone that it does exist and it's a
game that you know everyone there was a
darling game that ever wanted last year
unless they're going to show us loads
maybe it would be better to I think to
be unfortunate if it was a microsoft
exclusive because this is the kind of
thing you want on PlayStation with
morpheus and with you know oculus yes
they obviously that's going to take a
lot of is it really what do you want to
be getting sick all over yourself uh
yeah I mean like if you didn't get sick
in Valkyrie I think this could work and
what about battlefield hardline we've
already seen stuff leaked or Omaha as
they didn't want people to know about it
and yeah I know they're announcing some
stuff after e3 do you think it's gonna
have much of a presence at the show I
think it has to yeah yeah I think it's
just sort of like a thoroughly on the
whelming calm
cept really yeah in like it's it's not a
main line battlefield title and
battlefield all about scale and every
time they try to go like close quarters
urban it sort of been like okay that's
fun for a distraction but if they focus
an entire game on it probably maybe
something cool can come out of it I mean
I did like the Special Forces weapons
like the grappling hook and zip line and
that kind of thing yeah but I'm just not
really that interested in what it
actually is as we've seen so far a
dragon age any hype for dragon age mmm
well there we have really seen much in
terms of gameplay and I think everyone
just burned by the previous you know
what was what was the one that nobody
liked so too yeah and this is
Inquisition yes Inquisition basically
from the trailer it looks like it's
there's a Bolivian gate is opened or
they've got some different name for
that's what looks like demons ability
add on to the world on but it could be
really great but all about how they
executed combat and whether they stick
with their their old what they do best
like proper RPG or whether they're going
to try and action up again and
disappoint you 11 they can't figure out
whether to put a number on it or origins
or a subtitle yeah right it really shows
that actually don't know what they're
doing with that series it's a funny one
and it's change hands upon a time at
this stage as well right still by where
there's a fire risk well I guess Bioware
has been shaken up so much over the last
couple years again from 2k that see
anyone who's played this at a trade show
i said it's absolutely incredible but it
feels like there's hardly any
information about evolve like out there
uh it's it's almost like they made an
entire game out of the tank combat from
left 4 dead and really sort of like deep
dive how can we make this asymmetric
multiplayer work really well and be
balanced as well i think like the
balance is the key thing that's going to
make or break this what i played was
pretty balanced and you do have clutch
plays there are lots of like skillful
moments and that kind of thing i think
that it's it's going to be a really
really interesting one so which bill did
you play because recently the change
denier the ID yeah before that I place
like this first revealed builds right
okay let's change the class so they have
already experimenting that's how they're
going to balance and I like that they
are flexible like that because they
obviously know what's going to be you
know best for the titles is actual like
uncut gameplay here is how it actually
plays emotions yeah that's the perfect
way to actually see that and they showed
a bunch of pax east as well you know
there's a lot of covers that came out of
that so and that was a public event
obviously right so people have seen it
right now I think this is right
you said the time to really put it out
there because it's one of the few games
that's coming at this calendar year
those people to get excited about I
guess and Ubisoft are there the last of
the sort of the the big six or whatever
our big five at this stage to them that
have their own press conferences it
seems like most of their announcements
slipped out early like Assassin's Creed
unity was the first one a couple of
months ago you guys just got excited
about that at all I really wobbly but
but i'm not i'm pretty burnt out yes
really did you play black flag yes i did
and the sailing was great and that was
awesome but every time I had to get out
of the boat I was like a hawk oh not
again yeah kind of I've tried like three
or four times to get back in yeah and
actually let allow it to grab me and
it's yeah and this one they don't
haven't even said what is the thing that
is going to make this unique yeah so all
we know is right now it seems like
revolutionary Paris and you're an
assassin and that there is a next-gen
version and then one that is separate
that is coming out on current or is that
where we're at the other thing I guess
that one of the more interesting
rejuvenations of a franchisors they've
done recently as far cry like far cry 3
was one of my favorite games come at
that year obviously I'd standing they've
released the the concept image of the
new one which rubbed some people up the
wrong way but presumably they're going
to show some of this out there I see a
single prompt that says you were leaving
the mission area I'm just going are you
just waiting for another burn down crops
full of weed while yet longing it sweet
like file cries the series has sort of
been all over the place you know yeah 3
was sort of a combination of both
elements of 2 and 1 so it seems like
they've found their footing and this is
going to be so like far cry 3 take 22
are you guys excited about far cry from
really so much yeah 3 was my problem
with their best game from last year for
and the ability to combine the jungle
stuff with high mountains and elephants
and rhinos as well I think there's the
thing about Ubisoft though like they
want lightning to strike twice I mean
you saw how they revealed watchdogs and
then they revealed the vision and yes
that's the same way they're going to try
and have a new vas and I don't think
they're going to be able to live up to
that because that was sort of like um
flash in the pan you know like one time
thing it was amazing was great so
they've got a couple of other games that
I guess sir they've got actually got a
lot of games on the go at the moment the
crew is another one that we
shopping around for a while now have any
guys played the crew not yet now looks
like Borderlands in cars yeah I feel
like it doesn't seem particularly
interesting just looks so like rivals
for me as well examine more open world I
was gonna call this rubbish thing yeah I
was kind of hoping i get that like burn
a paradise hook from it may be like if
if it's interesting in that way like in
a new sort of like social way but was
just like fun and carefree you know it's
sort of like a big side peter brian what
was that reminds between driveclub and
the crew I mean I you know i mislike
really like core recent games and for me
that's the four so that's gran turismo
nigh like when those come out and i just
these games that come out to try to
experiment with that they show up and
then they disappear and no one cares
about it yeah and so I have a really
hard time getting excited for something
that's mean like what yeah am I looking
at here I don't know that's our video
game I hope my hope whoever's working on
this is not the same guys who did the
car driving or the car driving the
handling models and watchdog fingers
crossed and so perhaps the game that's
got the most hyper roundish especially
in relation to a III in particular is
the division and when they showed it off
was the two years ago now the first time
was last last last year yeah dude
shutting car door with his hand and one
freaking the hell out and we're not
gonna see this game for a while what do
they need to show this year to keep
people entertained I think the thing is
like they're really good at their first
reveals being slow and sedate and really
sort of absorbing and emotive so what
they're going to show this year is the
action side of it they're going to show
massive fire fights and you know those
kinds of division verse division
engagements that they've been sort of
hinting out at the end of that first
trailer well one of the things too like
they've been saying i guess the rumor is
that they've been working so much on the
tech side of things that the actual game
development is still pretty early yeah
so I'm really curious to see if what we
see this year will be drastically
different what was presented last year I
don't think it'll be too far off the
mark but I expect it's gonna look a
little bit different in terms of the
setting and the mechanics and everything
sort of plays together and we got a
bunch of questions coming in from folks
I want to just I got a few of them had
done before we continue at blurred cube
asks any chance of Rockstar showing up
Rockstar a funny one at e3 they tend to
not usually play that game there need to
yeah yeah so probably no one else didn't
I say it an earnings call that they had
something coming
before the next financial year like red
dead for PC if anything yeah would it be
or would it be or quantum thought of 5
for pc at this stage no the other way
because there's rumors about the next
gen GTA 5 this room is about next-gen
Skyrim like one that might be made
specifically for the cartels in next gen
GTA 5 4 4 pc GTA 5 i think you don't
think they do them at the same time
maybe no no separate em up yeah yeah so
it's weird rock star one of those
companies that kind of just do the wrong
thing they tend not to really need III
to show stuff off and another one the
charts been asking about how soon asks
and mass effect do we see something a
new mass effect this year or at least
like a glimmer i won I think that you
may get sort of like we had with mirrors
edge 2 at the end of that press
conference you'll probably get some Mass
Effect subtitle whatever it is they're
going with whether it's like the first
contact prequel or yeah you know 100
years and if you just see cool you're
probably not going to be playable at all
I don't know if you'll see any gameplay
but you're definitely going to get some
kind of teaser I think another game
we're likely to see as either or both
press conferences and probably a lot of
in terms of state your presence as well
is destiny at bungie have been sort of
they showed off a little bit last year
that got people excited about it is it
just me or am i is this game not as
exciting as I was kind of i'm not i feel
like i haven't hopped on the hype train
with this one yet I mean that's sort of
the unanimous impression that came out
of I think event that happened about a
month ago yes everyone sort of got their
hands on it was like all right it's sin
animo yeah what I don't know what's
what's really different here you know
and that sort of seemed I mean the world
is supposed to be interesting right
you've got some of the you know the
bungee things that that are persisting
here from the Halo universe in terms of
aesthetic and stuff but is it going to
be something great greater than just
another MMO made by Bungie leg about how
their shared world and you know
connectedness alley works that I don't
really actually understand how this is
multiplayer how this is a single player
and you know like how these things will
interact in the persistence and I feel
like people maybe feel like they've been
burned on watch dogs a bit because a lot
of that there was hinting us like these
vague recollections of what ash you know
connectedness is going to be in in the
end it was just people can enter your
game if you want them to so yeah I guess
we'll see if we got a bunch more games
to go through here at a game that I am
really really hoping is announced
I have heard that it probably won't be
Bethesda of since comment and said
they're not gonna answer anything what a
chance to seeing fallout 4 t's this year
i think p Hines was was kind of kind of
confirmed we're not going to see
anything didn't he was talking about bat
was it battle cry was that some other
game they're gonna talk okay which means
we're probably not i was also kind of
gunning for a mention of there yes honor
TV that's probably just me but then I if
it's no new IP then the rumors of the
skyrim HD version might still that could
still be a thing if that's a thing what
would you think about that Cameron who
has a weekly show about skyrim like
you'll probably get game a for like
people who are interesting that would
you play a ps4 and xbox one no i don't
see the point because you don't even
need a powerful pc these days to play
skyrim that looks great yeah Ian bees
and everything that you can build a
pretty budget PC you know no I don't
want to hate desk I'm are not a Skyrim
pre-installed with all the most amazing
mods why don't have to do it myself
right no that would be more valuable I
guess our driver yeah yeah that's like
you you guys been playing Skyrim there
for like three years off the back of the
pak'ma'ra like November Alex isn't that
the problem like i remember the Unreal
Tournament 3 on p on ps3 you could mod
but like just modding on consoles has
never really ever being a thing no i
think it's just too complicated with
them you know the potential for damaging
your game and you know the no one must
be liable for that so yeah i don't think
we'll see that but and civilizations be
on earth anyone anyone piped up about
yeah totally yeah I'm played
civilization since three because it just
been too similar yeah it did play off
the sanitary back in the day and I'll of
civilization I love space so yeah this
this is gonna be quite excited we don't
I want to see I want to get some proper
details about like how the mechanics are
going to work like how you started off
what type of units you're gonna get how
they like encounters with the aliens
that are on the planet's gonna be as it
just give me like barbarian cancers is
it gonna be different I really want to
get some details one quick sir you
couldn't play as aliens in ab Centauri
because you were just you or well or the
the I guess it wasn't really aliens was
it it was just the world yeah like the
world elements like the animals and
creatures wasn't yeah I think they were
just like in characters basically no I
won't know if alpha central it's been so
long game I played a lot off hotline
Miami hell I'm happy to do you think
wanna see some of that here we've got to
its it's coming out soon right that's
the thing like at this age I feel like
it's coming out in a couple of months
right yeah they've been
it was a pax east again like back in
April the name is that the console
exclusivity thing going already it's the
sort of thing it's only a place
PlayStation pcs right find exclusive on
PS and I should look this up before we
start I played it on PC yeah I'll
probably gonna pay it on pc too let's
see these regular games that you guys
are interested in which i think that
Square will show a bit more of the next
days x ok yeah days like to universe
whatever they're calling it they need
something to kind of prop themselves up
and I don't really know what they have
yet so learn is just more Final Fantasy
15 for sure Witcher 3 well today that
can get a lot of people really excited I
mean that game has been in development
for eight years now mm-hmm then there is
the wish of 33 yeah that's my that's my
most anticipated thing to see the whole
show I'm gonna see what more Witcher 3
awesome well from the sounds of it we've
been talking to have a bunch of mess
about video games for the past hour in a
bit and there's no shortage of cool
stuff to see at e3 this year so make
sure you stick on gamespot com all next
week now
you